so christina ricci i don't know if i've
ever been as entertained by something so
unsettling before
oh
yeah no it's a really fun show
yellowjackets
um when you got into this
did you sit with samantha to both decide
how you were going to play her because
your mannerisms and the way you walk and
the way you carry yourselves like have
you ever had to sit with another actor
to decide on how to play one character
before
no it was a brand new experience um
samantha and i did not meet before we
met before the pilot but we didn't
really discuss the character at length
um but then before we shot the second
episode after the show had been picked
up
we did meet to sort of go over um
go over the references she'd been given
by the eps the ones i've been given um
to discuss the differences that we were
going to infuse in our portrayals
um the mannerisms and stuff we did not
discuss that just sort of really
i don't know that there is another way
to push your glasses up
um
and she
yeah i guess we do have similar i guess
yeah we do have similar walks this show
wasn't really something that we went
over
yeah there's almost there's almost like
a punk aspect to to her where it's you
know when anarchy happens she'll be the
one you need you know it's almost like a
joker origin story um
yeah you don't see that especially those
kind of roles or those kind of
characters written for women
unless they're dressed like harley quinn
and uh
caricatures yeah so to see somebody
who's like kind of very normal um the
whole thing with the way she looked as
an adult is i wanted it to be a look
that you would see and think oh i've i
know that girl i've seen that woman
before
and she's supposed to be
grounded in reality but have this very
extreme personality which is somebody
who you know
the hotter the pot gets the more excited
she gets and she loves chaos and
you know
her life is so and i guess in a way yeah
she does feel like a comic book
character because like she is born of
extreme un unhappiness and duress
um which is sort of classic for
comic book characters they're usually
these very extreme characters
born from years of punishment and that
really is what she is and who she is and
her overarching
want and need is
connection and to be with people but she
because of the punishment she suffered
her whole life
she cannot
do it she self sabotages and um
she is just yeah she really she yeah she
does feel like a comic book character in
a lot of ways
did uh did people treat you differently
when you had the wig in the glasses on
yeah sammy and i both noticed that that
people would um
people would definitely treat us
differently once we were dressed which
is disappointing to say the least
yeah like what did you what did you find
what did you what did you did you people
treated us the way they would the way
that people in the story treated misty
and um really yeah yeah people are
co-workers you know people who should
not have immediately had a very base
reaction to seeing someone all of a
sudden in
ugly clothes no makeup
a horrible horrible hair and glasses
they
people did and people were dismissive
and would tease us and um
really kind of immediately you were in a
lower position than everybody else which
is really
fascinating to see
there's a practical side to the job as
well and i'm wondering um your husband
who's a hair stylist did he have an
opinion about the wig
no not really um no
no no
um uh you have a
matrix nobody knows anything about the
matrix nobody knows what they're even
doing but everybody is so excited are
you like a great secret keeper
yes i mean i did read the script um
i'm not allowed to talk about it and um
i will say it's really cool looking and
uh you know
the sets were amazing the production
design is amazing the hair and makeup is
incredible wardrobes fantastic
um
and the cast isn't incredible but you
know beyond that i can't really say
anything about it um could you talk
about was it getting to hang with keanu
reeves as fun as everybody might think
it would be yeah no he's wonderful he's
so nice and fun and
um charming and kind and generous and
just really it was really cool to work
with him i mean he's like
the ultimate movie star so it was really
cool to work with him
yeah i think when people put a list
together people that they'd like to hang
with keanu reeves is definitely on there
but also juliette lewis is on there it
would have been incredible to work with
juliette as well
it was great yeah i've known juliet for
a few years um
not not too well just sort of socially
and peripherally we've never worked
together so it was really fun to work
together
and because you guys really sort of came
up around the same
the same time
well she was someone definitely i
really looked up to when i was a
teenager and i wanted to be like her
um i remember asking somebody who had
worked with her what she ate
um when i was 14.
so i was really so it was yeah it was
great to to work with her we yeah
um you have with your career there's a
little bit of something in there for
everybody i have an eleven-year-old
daughter who grew up watching you in
movies that 11 year olds until the end
of time
will watch you in movies that are
designed for kids do you sort of keep
that in mind now that you you know when
you became a mom you're about to be a
mom again sort of leaving those
footprints behind when it comes to you
know the art but then there's also you
know sort of servicing your own family
and your own kids
um
no i'm not very good at being objective
and keeping the big picture in my head
at all um so
that is a good idea probably work that
into what i'm doing with my life um but
i tend to be much more like when it
comes to my work and my art like
more um impulsive and emotional and um i
guess maybe selfish in a way
you know feeding the needs of the artist
more than anything else